[Music]
[Applause]
the United Kingdom has one of the
largest and most competitive markets
anywhere in Europe and a man right at
the heart of fibre deployment for a
whole host of providers is Mike Makai
the chairman of open reach Mike thanks
for talking to us today I think before
we start tell us a bit about open region
where it sits in the UK market open
reach was created in 2006 as a result of
a regulatory intervention by Ofcom the
regulator it is the access network
provider in the UK it was separated out
of BT and it was set up to provide
equivalents of products access and so
forth to the access network for a range
of communication provider customers in
the UK now unfortunately the UK doesn't
fit too highly in the ftth council
statistics for Europe what's your
thoughts on and about when we're going
to get full fibre so at the focus that
we've had for the for the last I don't
know how many years has been very much
about solving the digital divide in the
UK making broadband accessible to the
vast majority if not all of the UK homes
and we are now at the position where we
have penetrations in the region of 4050
percent in the UK for superfast we have
coverage of around ninety five percent
as of the end of last year and as a
result of that whilst we still have the
last five percent to fill out which I'm
hoping that the industry will take care
of in their in in the coming few years
we've decided that it's time to build a
network of full fiber optic or fibre to
position us to continue to keep the UK
you know as the largest digital economy
in the g20 and during this time have you
found that your service providers are
being asked for fire but by their own
end-users I think it's a bit early for
that most end-users are quite happy with
the service they get there are many some
of which who are voluble who actually
don't get the service but that is
nothing to do with fiber that's all to
do with how they are currently served
but I think our communication provided
customers today are telling us that we
need to start building a network so that
when the demand is there we are ready to
fulfill it at scale because these these
these cps the likes of sky and talk talk
and indeed bt consumer they think they
need to be able to access a large scale
of population to make the investments
worthwhile on their part to actually
adopt the products so for them to sell
for fiber FTTP as we call it they need
to know that there are a million two
million or whatever it might be
potential homes out there that they can
market to and connect up and of course
there's a wholesaler i need them to be
able to do that because i don't make any
revenue until they connect somebody up
and start paying me for that service ok
Mike thanks very much for talking to us
thank you very much Brian my pleasure so
Openreach a real commitment to full
fiber for the UK
[Music]
[Applause]